[Musica]
capita spesso di essere insultati
molestati criticati ferocemente gli
hanno mai detto che dimostrate 15 anni
di più gli hanno mai chiesto se il
vostro doppio mento abbia un suo account
su twitter vi hanno mai suggerito di non
fare i figli perché un figlio di certo
non la vorrebbe una madre come voi
quante volte vi hanno augurato di morire
ammazzata e di femminicidio o di essere
stuprata da un branco di [ __ ]
cito testualmente a me è capitato
piuttosto spesso ma non c'è niente di
cui stupirsi perché sono una blogger una
che si potrebbe definire influencer o
micro influencer se volete farmi venire
complessi di inferiorità
fatto sta che essere un personaggio
pubblico cosiddetto esposta dovrebbe
legittimare il fatto che ogni giorno
devo far fronte a una pletora di
individui pronti a stracciarsi le palle
su qualsiasi cosa
qualsiasi cosa qualche tempo fa per
esempio una tizia si è incazzata con me
perché secondo lei nelle stories su
instagram mi sforzavo di camuffare il
mio accento ho provato a dirle ma no
guarda vivo fuori da tanti anni può
succedere ha detto che no io lo facevo
volutamente e lei lo sapeva con certezza
assoluta
un'altra tizia mi manda periodicamente
dell'email minacciose perché proprio non
sopporta il fatto che io l'abbia
bloccata sui miei social che io vorrei
dirle amica fattene una ragione e il mio
blog e la mia pagina e del mio diritto
metterti alla porta se fai la stronza
morale nel giro di 8 anni sono diventata
una hayter degli haters ma non è sempre
stato così il fatto che non ci sono più
gli haters di una volta quelli un tempo
erano creativi originali si sbattevano
un casino per farsi notare
mario ciampi per esempio ne fece un
fotomontaggio talmente divertente che
decisi di pubblicarlo ringraziandolo era
un before and after come quello delle
vere celebrities paolo peroni invece mi
commentava sempre quello stesso
messaggio morirai grassa spariva per
giorni settimane e quando tornava mi
diceva sempre la stessa cosa morirai
grassa
a un certo punto ha iniziato a scrivermi
solo mg
tuttavia quando ho compiuto 30 anni ho
pubblicato una fotografia della festa e
in quell'occasione invece paolo peroni
mi ha detto che ero bella e mi ha fatto
gli auguri
vedete per quanto sinistri fossero gli
haters di un tempo erano più mani erano
come i bambini che fanno i dispetti per
attirare l'attenzione della mamma o
della maestra solo che negli ultimi otto
anni molte cose sono cambiate intorno a
noi siamo cambiati noi e sono cambiati
anche gli haters ma facciamo un passo
indietro quando nel 2011 ho aperto il
blog memorie di una vagina
non ho pensato alle conseguenze non
avevo un progetto editoriale preciso in
mente e non immaginavo che la community
sarebbe diventata una piccola officina
di opinioni al femminile mentre scrivevo
mi rendevo conto di dar voce ai pensieri
di molte donne e post come i
noleggiatori e caro maschio
contemporaneo con le loro oltre 100.000
condivisioni nero non chiaro segnale
adoro che ci sia dell'ilarità in sala
in entrambi i casi però si trattava di
post che trasudavano sessismo un
sessismo bianco dico io temporaneo
passeggero un sessismo che era anche la
necessità di rivendicare una prospettiva
femminile sulla sessualità tutta
dall'iniziativa alla percezione del
proprio corpo passando per il sesso
orale l'orgasmo il mitologico punto g
classificare le tipologie di pene altro
post di discreto successo non era altro
che la risposta decenni in cui noi donne
eravamo state carne esposta in
macelleria quotata è messa all'asta per
il miglior offerente
sono certa di aver visto molte più
grafiche con tutte le tipologie di tette
culi e vulve di quante ne abbia mai
viste sul pene o in generale sul corpo
degli uomini perché dico tutto questo
per premettere che non sono stata
politicamente corretta particolarmente
diplomatica o sempre perfettamente
equilibrata nei giudizi in questi anni e
lo riconosco tuttavia dar voce a quei
pensieri che erano miei e di moltissime
altre donne era una parte fondamentale
del mio lavoro perché il mio lavoro era
ed è avere una voce sfacciatamente
femminile e difenderla che come potete
immaginare non è un mestiere facile da
spiegare un interlocutore
prova ne è il fatto che in questi anni
alcune aziende non hanno voluto
collaborare con me per via del mio nome
e in molti mi hanno suggerito di creare
un progetto parallelo di affrancarmi dal
peso della pagina ma io non l'ho fatto
non avrei potuto eliminare la vagina dal
mio nome senza eliminare la ragione dal
mio blog senza negare la sua vocazione
più autentica che la femminilità
soprattutto io non volevo chiamarmi pink
fashion tips perché non me ne fregava
niente di parlare di moda di make up di
ricette io volevo parlare del grasso di
cui mi vergognavo delle aspettative che
mi soffocavano del passato che mi
tormentava e del futuro che mi
spaventava in questi otto anni ho
scritto di molti argomenti più o meno
scomodi di sesso evidentemente ma anche
di vita da single proprio mentre le the
thing up mutavano antropologicamente
connotati della relazione tra i generi
ho scritto di amore soprattutto della
sua mancanza dei suoi spenti dei suoi
rimpianti delle ferite delle promesse
ho parlato di body shiming molto prima
che questo neologismo anglofono
diventasse comune nel nostro vocabolario
condiviso
ho scritto di amicizia ai tempi di
whatsapp di famiglia di rapporti umani
di migrazione perché anche io nel mio
piccolo sono una migrante
quello che cerco di dirvi è che in
questi otto anni ho attirato le
antipatie di una moltitudine di soggetti
diversi che non si sono di certo
trattenuti dall esprimere in maniera per
lo più aggressiva il loro disappunto nei
confronti della mia persona della mia
voce delle mie idee
oltre che naturalmente del mio aspetto
fisico quegli insulti pieni di livore
quelle insinuazioni basse quei commenti
brutali superficiali come i device
attraverso cui vengono inviati
rappresentano la parte più sgradevole
del mio lavoro
a volte si tratta di critiche di
un'assoluta stupidità da parte di
personale cui sinapsi evidentemente
implodono di fronte alle insidie di un
periodo subordinato e ciò nonostante
quelle critiche agiscono sul mio umore
mi scoraggiano e non per i colpi inferti
al mio ego mi scoraggiano perché toccare
con mano il livello di rabbia di
marginalità di rifiuto di nvidia di
intolleranza che permea la nostra
società e i nostri social e scoraggiante
e scoraggiante perché ogni volta non
posso fare a meno di pensare questa
persona vuota e se ha dei figli
mi chiedo quali valori li educhi infine
mi domando cosa abbia reso la sua vita
così vuota e così triste da consentirle
di perdere un'intera giornata a litigare
con estranei nei commenti del post di
una pagina che odia
[Applauso]
la risposta più plausibile che ho
trovato a questa domanda è che chi passa
molto tempo sui social e molto solo e
per carità ho scoperto l'acqua calda si
lo so però il punto su cui vorrei porre
l'accento è un altro e cioè che queste
persone molto sole che passano molto
tempo sui social c'è servano ci servano
mentre siamo tutti impegnati ad apparire
il più possibile belli felici in forma
pieni di amici di soldi di gatti mentre
facciamo chef della nostra vita delle
nostre vacanze delle nostre cene fuori
dei nostri matrimoni persino dei nostri
figli
queste persone molto sole che passano
ore interminabili ad abitare un mondo
che non esiste si sentono ogni santo
giorno più brutte più povere più sole
più abbandonate più dimenticate degli
altri
ora io me la sto raccontando a tinte un
po fosche ma instagram è oggettivamente
una macchina capace di alimentare e al
tempo stesso disintegrare l'autostima di
chiunque
solo che molti di noi per fortuna hanno
anche altro nella vita hanno un lavoro
una famiglia degli amici dei sogni dei
progetti delle passioni un'altra parte
di noi però non è altrettanto fortunata
non ha un lavoro oa un lavoro che odia
non ha una famiglia felice non ha tanti
amici non ha sogni non ha progetti non
sente di avere un ruolo né di fare la
differenza quell'altra parte di noi ha
un bisogno disperato di vomitare la sua
frustrazione e lo fa nel luogo ideale lo
fa sui social il regno della finta
perfezione
se ci pensate sui social non mostriamo
mai coscientemente il peggio di noi
stessi
nel senso che chi lo fa di solito lo fa
sua insaputa sui social non diciamo la
verità ci vantiamo dei nostri successi e
occulti amo i nostri fallimenti
raramente li usiamo per confessare
risentirci danneggiati umiliati e
traditi fragili depressi dipendenti da
sostanze o da persone
i social non sono la verità
e il peggio sui social noi l'abbiamo
rinnegato l'abbiamo cacciata dalla porta
e quello è rientrato da ogni finestra
fessura e pertugio che abbia incontrato
esattamente come liquame putrido di una
cloaca che tracima
a questo proposito mi viene in mente un
proverbio che dice spesso mia madre che
dice spesso proverbi per farmi capire le
cose se ciascuno di noi stendesse al
sole i suoi guai tutti riprenderebbero
in casa i propri
in altri termini le nostre miserie le
nostre difficoltà i nostri problemi ci
sembrano insormontabili
quando ci persuade amo chi siano gli
unici al mondo quando ci isoliamo quando
ci alleniamo nelle nostre bolle di
opinione e vi sia sufficiente viaggiare
su un mezzo pubblico aspettare in una
sala d'attesa a mangiare un boccone al
bar da soli per accorge di quanto tutti
siamo alienati con le nostre stampelle
tecnologiche i social non sono la verità
ricordate lo sempre ogni volta che
vedete le fotografie di certifichi
pazzeschi in vacanza in posti pazzeschi
con outfit pazzeschi il resort pazzeschi
ricordate che quasi certamente quelle
persone stanno combattendo la diarrea
[Applauso]
o la stitichezza o il tasso di umidità
al 90 per cento o le zanzare più feroci
del pianeta seconde solo a quelle di
milano i social sono una vetrina non
sono la realtà anche se la realtà come
abbiamo visto anche prima la influenzano
ne condizionano le scelte le opinioni
politiche ne intaccano il sistema
culturale e immunitario ma non sono la
realtà quando metti piede nella realtà
ti accorgi che un po diversa nella
realtà per esempio non è mai successo
che qualcuno mi fermasse per insultarmi
in mezzo alla strada
al contrario nella realtà mi è capitato
un sacco di volte di essere fermata e
ringraziata per tutto quello che faccio
qualunque cosa sì esattamente
e sia chiaro che mettere un piede nella
realtà non è sufficiente bisogna anche
alzare la testa dallo smartphone
bisogna osservare sentire percepire
leggere bisogna essere persone non
profili persone capaci di comunicare con
altre persone con le parole con i
silenzi con gli sguardi con i gesti
persone capaci di parlare e soprattutto
di ascoltare capaci di comprendere
altrettanto capaci di spiegare che ci
sembrano tutti attività banali invece
sono complesse sono impegnative
specialmente nella misura in cui tutti
almeno un po ci siamo disabituati a
farle se noi ci sentissimo di più come
esseri umani e non come pure identità
digitali
vedremo che anche chi a bellissimi
profili su instagram
a volte si sente deluso abbandonato
tradito pieno di ansie di paure di
nevrosi capiremmo che siamo tutti la
stessa canticchiate danzante e merda del
mondo come direbbe palaniuk capiremmo
che siamo tutti uguali
sebbene tutti diversi e capiremo anche
che un male comune si risolve insieme e
per fare una cosa insieme per essere
dalla stessa parte
non è necessario essere tutti omologati
tutti dello stesso colore della stessa
taglia della stessa religione tutti
rifatti dallo stesso chirurgo tutti
tifosi della stessa squadra dello stesso
partito per fare una cosa insieme
una cosa che serve a tutti basta essere
umani sentirsi umani mostrarsi umani
tutti uguali e tutti i liberi di essere
diversi
prima di salutarvi
vorrei dirvi che ultimamente sto
riflettendo moltissimo sul concetto di
diversità le opinioni diverse corpi
diversi di abilità diverse le culture
diverse e sull'insofferenza che la
diversità ci procura lo capisco perché
la diversità e faticosa le queste belle
spesso lo sono
la democrazia e faticosa l'amore è
faticoso il lavoro e faticosa anche il
sesso a suo modo è faticoso ma se c'è
una certezza che ho nella mia vita
disorganica di millennio interrotta e
che non è mai un buon segno quando gli
esseri umani iniziano a non sopportare
più la diversità quando non hanno più
voglia di capirla di includerla di
considerarlo una virtù e non un
disvalore
vuol dire che non sopportano più la
libertà degli altri di essere diversi
quale che sia la declinazione di quella
diversità vuol dire che si fa una
classifica della libertà come se la
libertà potesse essere di qualcuno e non
fosse per definizione libera cioè di
tutti oppure di nessuno diffidate non
diffidate guardatevi bene dalle persone
che non sopportano più
la diversità siate molto prudenti
ascoltate le fate le parlare parlateci
anche se le loro parole potrebbero
causare un travaso di bile e dopo quando
hanno finito di spiegare le loro ragioni
con poca supponenza con tutta l'empatia
di cui siete capaci
intuendo al meglio il contesto socio
culturale in cui quella persona ha
formato quelle opinioni
provate a dirle che c'è un'altra
versione della storia provate a farle
capire che attraverso la diversità di
ciascuno passa la libertà di tutti
anche la sua provate a farle capire che
la diversità e l'altro volto della
libertà ed è per questo che la diversità
va accettata rivendicata difesa
dunque invece che affaticarci per essere
tutti uguali tutti con la stessa faccia
le stesse bocca e le stesse bocce le
stesse borse proviamo a rivendicare
innanzitutto noi la nostra diversità
sempre facciamoci portatori sani di
contaminazione e di varietà di
narrazioni e di prospettive altre
teniamoci i nostri nasi storti le nostre
labbra sottili le nostre tettine piccine
i nostri culi non brasiliani perché
scusateci ma non siamo nati a rio de
janeiro
difendiamo la nostra imperfezione la
nostra umanità la nostra unicità e al
tempo stesso impariamo ad accettare la
diversità altrui sono due operazioni che
viaggiano di pari passo non possono
prescindere l'una dall'altra anche se ci
sono situazioni in cui è molto difficile
accettare la diversità altrui tipo su un
intercity lecce milano a fine agosto con
l'aria condizionata rotta lo so
ciononostante come esseri umani dobbiamo
ricordare che abbiamo un valore tutti
che la nostra diversità e la nostra
libertà hanno un valore che le guance
che arrossiscono hanno un valore che i
diritti umani hanno un valore che la
nostra vita a un valore e abbiamo il
dovere da esseri umani di alzarlo quel
valore perché sta scendendo molto in
fretta
in picchiata libera sta sfondando al
ribasso una soglia troppo pericolosa per
tutti dobbiamo rialzarci dobbiamo
farcela dobbiamo odiare di meno per
stare tutti un po meglio
dobbiamo difendere la libertà di tutti
dobbiamo rispettare la diversità di
tutti dobbiamo essere umani uguali e
diversi così come siamo
fine della storia grazie della battaglia
[Applauso]